Building a Java project doesn't
seem too bad at first glance.
You just call Java C on your source
files and it spits out some class files.
You can also copy over resources
like images and strings.
For distribution, you can Jar up
your class files and resources and
you're done, right?
Well, you might also want to
generate some documentation.
Running some unit tests probably sounds
like it would be a good idea as well.
If you're getting really serious, you
might even want to run multiple sets of
unit tests,
including integration acceptance tests.
Then, assuming those tests pass,
you might want to deploy
your Jar to a repository.
This is starting to sound like its
a lot of work to do by hand, but
not impossible, right?
Or you could write a shell script
that would automate this process.
It'd be messy but it's doable.
Android apps on the other
hand are beasts.
The Java source isn't compiled
as standard Java byte code, but
to custom byte code for
the Android run time.
Android has three different
types of resources that
all get packaged differently.
There's an additional wrinkle in that
the resources that you define need
to be pooled together with resources
coming from your included libraries.
And the identifiers of all those
resources need to be known beforehand,
before anything else gets compiled.
Also, Android apps most be
cryptographically signed.
When you put all that together,
it looks something like this.
Now, considering you might want to build
both Debug and Release versions of your
app, you might also want to
build free and paid variance.
The point is,
is that the process of building Android
app is not something we can do by hand.
It's not even something that
we can do in a shell script.
We need a more robust solution.
That solution comes to Android
in the form of Gradle.